-A Senate report provides
damning new details
about Donald Trump's attempts
to get the Justice Department
to overturn the election
and, yet, former Trump allies
who criticized him
for the attempted coup,
like Nikki Haley and Mike Pence,
are pathetically
falling back in line.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
If you recall -- and I know
it's hard to remember,
since it happened approximately
78 years ago --
Donald Trump whipped up
a violent mob
to attack the Capitol
and stage an insurrection,
in order to overturn the results
of a free and fair election.
I'm no lawyer, but that, alone,
seems to me like a crime worthy
of jail time.
And by the way,
when I say I'm not a lawyer,
that doesn't mean
I don't know lawyers.
I feel like everyone
I know is a lawyer.
The other day, I was
at the dentist's office,
getting a cleaning, and, when I
mentioned a parking ticket,
my hygienist said,
"Do you need representation?"
and gave me his card.
Although,
I should be clear,
my dental hygienist
is Rudy Giuliani.
I'm sorry.
He's just cheaper.
I think it's because he uses
helium, instead of nitrous.
I say that because it always
hurts a ton
and, when I scream in pain,
it sounds like this --
[ Donald Duck voice ]
No! Dad, no!
[ Laughter ]
Alright.
And, yet, it seems like,
not only is Trump likely
to avoid jail,
but, according to a report
from earlier this week,
he wants to run
for president again.
-New reporting on Donald Trump's
future presidential ambitions.
Three sources tell
The Washington Post
that Trump asked advisors
whether he should announce
his 2024 bid for the White House
after the chaotic exit
in Afghanistan
and those advisors
urged "patience."
That's the quote, patience.
But, behind the scenes,
there's concern
that Democrats could benefit
during the 2022 midterms,
if Trump decides to jump
into the presidential race
before that.
-It says a lot
about how unpopular Trump is,
that his advisors had
to tell him to wait
to announce his candidacy,
or it would help Democrats.
But would anyone really be
shocked if he ran again?
He tried everything,
in and out of his power,
to stay in the White House,
even though he lost.
He begged the Georgia
secretary of state
to find some votes, like he was
Jack Lemmon in a phone booth.
Assuming he's not going
to run again
is like hitting Michael Myers
with a car
and thinking the movie's over.
"Oh, he fell down.
Okay, we're all safe now.
We can turn our backs on him."
Trump probably understands
the place he'd be safest
from his current legal troubles
is the White House,
so, it makes sense he'd want
to get back there.
He treats the job less like
a massive responsibility
and more like a safe base
in a game of middle school tag.
[ As Trump ]
I'm touching the
Oval Office wall.
I'm safe when
I'm touching the wall.
You can't arrest me.
So Trump is reportedly
considering running again
and other aspiring Republicans
have said
they'll wait
until he makes the decision
before they decide
to run themselves.
-Former UN Ambassador
Nikki Haley
now says the Republican Party
needs former President Trump
and she'll consult with him,
if she makes a bid
for the White House.
-She called Donald Trump
a friend
and said she would consult
with him
before launching a run
for the White House.
-"We need him
in the Republican Party.
I don't want us to go back
to the days before Trump."
-You don't?!
What was wrong
with the days before Trump,
too many alive people?
Not enough breaking news alerts?
There was so much insanity
during Trump
that the breaking news banner
was seared into my flatscreen
even when it was off.
But that tells you
everything right there.
They want the Trump years
back again.
That's what happens when you're
a boring, soulless hack
who's dedicated your life
to pursuing power above all else
in a place like
official Washington,
where everyone around you is
a balding weirdo
with no interests,
aside from raising money
and running for things,
or maybe writing one of these
airport terminal dust catchers.
The Nikki Haleys of the world
used to spend their time
at boring
think tank cocktail parties
where the hot topic was
who's getting invited
to the Heritage Foundation
Christmas party, then, suddenly,
an amoral reality show psycho
like Trump comes along
and uses dirty words and they
think they're in Hollywood now.
It's like when you go
to Times Square
for the first time
and think you're meeting
the real Iron Man.
"He said he was going to use
his jet boots to fly away,
but then, I saw him smoking
a cigarette on the F train."
[ Laughter ]
That's what happened
to Lindsey Graham.
He started out hating Trump,
like Trump was a slick
out-of-towner dating his meemaw,
but then, Graham realized
he could be in show business,
and everything changed.
[ As Graham ]
Meemaw, Mr. Trump says
he's going to get me a job
in the pictures.
I just need to give him $200
for new headshots.
What do you mean,
how am I going to get $200?!
We're going to sell the farm,
you old coot!
[ Laughter ]
That's why Nikki Haley wants
Trump days back
and why she suddenly considers
Trump her friend again,
after telling Politico,
earlier this year,
that he was no longer welcome
in national politics.
Let's be honest -- these people
were always going
to forgive him.
Republicans are like
the rich housewife
who finds lipstick
on her husband's collar
and tells her friend,
"He says he got it
because he slipped and fell
into a makeup counter.
And you know the floor
of Bloomingdale's
is like an ice skating rink."
[ Laughter ]
So the Nikki Haleys
and Lindsey Grahams of the world
briefly distance themselves
from Trump
and then quickly fell back
in line,
despite the fact
that he repeatedly tried
to overturn the results
of a free and fair election
and destroy our democracy.
And it isn't like January 6th
with just some protest
that got out of hand
after an impulsive Trump
vented his frustrations.
They had a plan. In fact,
they had multiple plans.
As we've explained before,
one of Trump's lawyers,
a guy named John Eastman,
even wrote an instruction manual
for Mike Pence,
laying out exactly how
to overturn
the election results,
which he did not have
the power to do.
Trump even brought them together
in the Oval Office
to try to convince Pence
to go through with it.
-Stunning new details
on Donald Trump's efforts
to overturn the 2020 election
from the new book "Peril,"
by Bob Woodward
and Robert Costa.
The authors report on a two-page
memo drafted by John Eastman.
John Eastman
is a conservative lawyer
who was working
for Trump's legal team.
It amounts to a blueprint
for a coup.
NBC News has later
obtained the memo.
It outlines how Pence was
to have disrupted
the certification of the
Electoral College results
and handed the election
to Trump.
Trump tells Pence this
about Eastman --
-But even weirder are
the juvenile tactics Trump used
to try to persuade Pence
to go through with it.
The following day,
on the morning of January 6th,
he reportedly called Pence
and taunted...
So he uses the same tactics
as a 14-year-old trying
to convince his friend
to steal a KitKat
from a convenience store.
"Just hide it under your shirt."
I can't do that.
"But wouldn't it be like cool,
if you did?
[ Laughter ]
I don't know if I can be friends
with a wimp, Mike."
Also, I love that Trump was the
most powerful man in the world,
with virtually unlimited
resources at his fingertips,
and, yet, he thought
his biggest leverage
was threatening not to be
Mike Pence's friend anymore.
You're a terrible friend.
I doubt Mike Pence was thinking,
"Oh, no, now who's going
to help me with my sofa
next time I have to move?"
Also, we know about all this.
Can you imagine
what we don't know about?
So far,
Bob Woodward's Trump books
have been called "Fear,"
"Rage," and "Peril,"
but, at this rate, he's going
to have to call the next one...
Yet, Pence is now doing
the same song and dance
as Nikki Haley,
and acting like that whole
mob riot thing was no big deal.
-The president and I sat down
a few days later
and talked through all of it.
I can tell you that we
parted amicably
at the end of the administration
and we've talked
a number of times
since we both left office.
But, I believe
that our entire focus today
should be on the future.
I know the media wants
to distract
from the Biden administration's
failed agenda
by focusing on one day
in January.
-"One day in January"?
If there was a day where
a violent mob was chanting,
"Hang Seth Meyers," I wouldn't
call it "one day in January."
I'd call it "the day I moved
to Portugal and grew a beard."
[ Laughter ]
"One day in January"
sounds like a sports movie
starring Al Pacino
as a past-his-prime
football coach.
[ As Pacino ]
Boom! Alright!
[ Laughter ]
Let's pick a play.
We got a passing play.
We got running plays.
How about this --
we just hang
the opposing quarterback.
[ Laughter ]
That's hard-nosed
football, muchacho.
[ Laughter ]
Last day to do my Pacino.
Oh, I meant last day
to do my Pacino
without a standing ovation.
[ Laughter ]
And that wasn't the only
Oval Office meeting
where Trump tried to pressure
a senior government official
to help him overthrow democracy.
We also know that one
of his henchmen
in the Justice Department,
a guy named Jeffrey Clark,
had a detailed plan for getting
the Justice Department
to interfere and declare
there was fraud in the election,
which there was not.
And, now, thanks to a new report
from the
Senate Judiciary Committee,
we have more details about that
plan and that meeting.
-After an eight-month
investigation,
the Senate Judiciary Committee
today will release a report
on how the Trump administration
attempted to subvert the law,
in an effort to keep
the president in office.
The report provides new details
on the efforts
of then-Acting Assistant
Attorney General Jeffrey Clark,
as he attempted to do
the bidding of President Trump.
-The president
of the United States decided
to put full court pressure
on the new acting attorney
general, Jeffrey Rosen.
And, as I said before,
he was relentless.
When you look
at the number of contacts --
we're still waiting
for even more evidence
to come in on that subject --
he was really pushing
the Department of Justice
to bend to his political will
and I will tell you,
just, I don't think
I'm overstating the case.
We were a half step away
from a full-blown
constitutional crisis.
-Now, of course, half a step
is still a lot for Trump,
given how he takes steps.
[ Laughter ]
I've never seen a person
as confident as him
walk as gingerly as he does.
He walks down a ramp
like a deer on a frozen pond.
If you couldn't see his shoes,
you'd think
he was wearing roller skates
for the first time.
But that's how close we came.
Trump tried every avenue
he could think of --
the courts, the states,
the vice president,
the Justice Department.
He's like the guy
in gridlock traffic
who keeps switching lanes
and then throws his hands up
when it doesn't work.
We're on the FDR
at 5:00 in the afternoon.
There's no secret way out,
buddy.
In the end, the only thing
that stopped Trump, apparently,
was a threat from senior
DOJ officials to resign.
As The New York Times
reported yesterday,
just days
before the insurrection,
Trump held a meeting
in the Oval Office
about his plans for a coup.
Pretty dramatic language.
Woodward's going to have
to up the ante on the next book
even more than I thought.
Although,
"murder-suicide pact" probably
sounded good to Trump
when he first heard it.
[ As Trump ]
So I murder you and then,
you commit suicide?
[ Laughter ]
I think I --
I think I saw something
like that once on "SVU."
[ Laughter ]
"SVU."
We love "SVU," don't we, folks?
A great,
a great American program.
We love Mr. Ice-Lemonade
and Richard Seltzer.
[ Laughter ]
A real original.
Detective John Munch!
[ Laughter ]
Richard Seltzer started
as a comedian.
People don't know that.
But I remember I saw him
in 1983
at Catch a Rising Star.
[ Laughter ]
Nice guy. Good guy.
Hated my guts.
The GOP has fallen back in line
behind a guy
who did everything he could
to overthrow democracy
and absolutely will try again,
if given the chance.
A chance he, apparently,
very much wants.
The details in the Senate
report are damning
and there are almost
certainly more to come.
There's enough material
in here --
in here -- excuse me --
for ESPN --
Wow, this is a real tee-up.
I don't know
where this is going.
You guys, I never know what
the last clip's going to be.
That's something, you know,
we're just going to share it.
You know, this is our last night
without an audience.
Let's just talk
to the people at home
[ Laughter ]
and let them inside,
behind the curtain, so to speak.
There's enough material here
for ESPN
to do a four-part
"30 for 30" and call it...
-One day in January.
Hm.
[ Laughter ]
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.